I think trying to get to the NBA or
trying to do anything that is
extraordinary and also very improbable
just by statistics when you when you
look at something like that you have to
have a crystal clear picture of what
you're trying to achieve but more than
that you have to have I think a really
pragmatic assessment of who you are at
the beginning one of the things about
goal-setting that makes me a little
crazy is that people always think it's
about looking into the future looking to
5 10 years into the future and knowing
that's what you're going to get and then
they just set off without any clue about
where they are right now and you know
just in terms of simple cartography you
can't get anywhere if you don't know
where you are now so for me when I
started off it was a question of looking
at myself and saying yes I'm fat I'm a
fat 17 year old in England I'm a nerd I
like to sit in the library I don't like
to sweat and yeah at the same time I've
been captivated by the idea of being on
a basketball court and being surrounded
by people who made me look a little bit
less like a freak and so in order to get
to the NBA this ultimate point I had
watched Larry Bird and Magic Johnson at
the time playing and I was like that's
what I want to be so from then knowing
who I was I put steps in place knowing
that I'd have to get in shape knowing
that I'd have to stay motivated knowing
that I'd probably have to leave home in
order to become a basketball player of
any note so I set up a plan that looked
that had all these different stages in
but also allowed me flexibility because
the thing about plans is that they tend
to go wrong at certain stages you tend
to let yourself down environmental
factors step in and mean that you aren't
where you thought you would be at a
certain point in great plans allow
flexibility they allow you to revise
your position and yet still stay on the
ladder
I think the more unlikely the goal that
you are trying to achieve the more
logistically sound a plan has to be it
is one thing to want to be a you know
senior manager of a department shop
somewhere not that in this economy is
particularly easy but it's certainly
more probable than many other types of
job and so to get that way perhaps you
don't need to identify every single type
of shop on what their particular needs
might be and what each of these shots
might be looking for in a person but in
order to play in the NBA you need to
know exactly what the NBA is looking for
you need to know how close to that you
can get you need to know you know for me
there were simple things like I knew the
NBA was looking for athletes and and I
knew I wasn't one so I also knew that I
didn't really like to sweat and work
hard so I had to find a trainer who I
could respond to and you had to know my
personality type so I didn't find
someone who was a screamer I found
someone who showed his disappointment if
I wasn't working hard and I found that
was the way to motivate me I knew I was
kind of lazy so I built my house you
know five hundred meters away from where
my trainer trained athletes so there was
never an excuse I could just fall out of
bed and be there ready to go every day
knowing yourself knowing where you want
to get combining those things gives you
the pragmatic steps